Cities.
We had to be very careful when we have these discussions,
not to devalue the human dignity of people who aren't in the upper end of the
distribution.
If there's one criticism that I think is fair is sometimes in these
conversations,
it sounds like we're devaluing people at the lower end of the distribution.
We have to be very careful that we don't do that.
A human life has dignity and Iq was not the most important thing that defines
human gifts.
We beams EAGAN.
It's
not associated with wisdom.
It's not necessarily associated with truth or with courage or with many virtues
that are how.
Right.
Get it.
You in it at all with being likable or on
the psychometric,
which the psychometric relationship between intelligence and conscientiousness
is zero.
Right.
We have to make that point.
Yes,
I agree.
I'm trying to make the point about how difficult it is for people who are on the
low end of the cognitive spectrum to survive in a,
in an increasingly complex,
cognitively sophisticated environment.